[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar accelerating commercialization
with custom oem solutions and gmp
i'm kaylie bach and i'll be your
moderator for today's event which is
presented by lab roots
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by sativa and integrated
dna technologies to learn more please
visit sativallifesciences.com
and ibtdna.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
matthew davies custom service leader at
saitiva
amy webster custom projects leader at
sativa mitch gore
innovation product manager pcr and core
eligos at idt
and renee rafcen
commercial product manager pcr and
coraligos at idt
matthew amy mitch and renee you may now
begin your presentation
uh thank you very much
so
quick agenda of what we're going to
cover today so and the first part is
going to be the custom scientific
customized solutions team
uh what we do who we are and then going
into detail about one of our services
which we call the live stable so freeze
drying what we do why we do it how we do
it
what our capabilities are both on the r
d scale and in the manufacturing scale
and how we would take your product from
small-scale r d into full-blown
manufacture we'll then pass over to
mitra renee idt and they will take you
through the
history and capabilities of idt both in
their gmp and 13485 capabilities and
also their large-scale capabilities and
what they can do for
your custom formulations and your custom
kits
so starting off with sciteva's
customized solutions team
we're a team of scientists that are
dedicated to helping you solve your
problem
we're roughly split into five different
services the lyophilization or lyo
stable service which we will be going
through in more detail today
we also have custom biology so
our catalog products we can create a
custom version for your sales with your
custom pack size or slightly different
components if needed
our ceramic and beads we can customize
we can see different differences in
concentration formulation pack sizes but
we can also conjugate
ideologues to it antibodies things like
that
contract manufacturing if you have a
buses that you need to make and pack
into your own label tubes something we
can do
and our
96 well filter plates we can
put in a custom membrane for you as well
so it takes a couple of minutes to go
through my optimization and our life
stable service
so blood optimization or freeze drying
is the process where we
solidify and stabilize and assay enzyme
rna reagent by first freezing it and
then by dehydrating it and removing the
water
so how we do this is we take it down
below its triple point so
below the point at which
so below the triple points
a
mix will go
from a solid state straight to a gas
state so
in the freeze drying process the ice is
sublime straight into a gas this is then
removed from the product by being caught
in the condenser
this leaves us with a really dry
cake and the structure of the cake
allows it to reconstitute really simply
upon addition of the sample when you run
the assay
to do this we also need to add
protectants so particularly enzymes
they don't like being frozen and they
don't like being dehydrated so we have a
range of proprietary recipients that we
will add to your reagents to protect
them during this process
so how we lay off the lives we have your
bespoke reagents we have reagents from
idt's like oligos enzymes things like
that we then combine both of them
together and formulate them and add our
proprietary excipient mix
to stabilize and protect all the
reagents
we then have two options we can dispense
them and
and then lyophilize them and this is our
cake format
or we can turn them into beads
lyophilize them and then dispense them
and that is what we call b format
with both of them we can use
tubes or custom plastic wear that you
won't require for your asset
this slide shows results from a
quantitative research study that was
commissioned by sativa last year
highlighting
both the reasons why we lay off the
lights and also for reliabilized assay
what are the critical parts of it
for example if you're talking a
point-of-care diagnostic test you want
the
you want to be able to store it for
long-term at ambient conditions this
allows you to shift at ambience and also
store our ambience saving both money and
reducing carbon emissions
but what we also need is for this to be
to have comparable activity to the
benchtop assay so this is something that
cytima can work with you to develop so
that we
have the long-term storage and
reliability that we need in the nasa
okay so the types of assays that we can
do this with or we have done this with
we've done
lamp assays we've done multiplex ppcr
and also rt-pcr assays we've done
enzymes on their own we've done rna and
dna on their own we have a range of
simplifying genomic kits that we have
both catalog versions and also custom
versions that we can do
and the magnetic beads we can conjugate
and then we can also lyophilize those as
well
now going for a bit more as to sativa
and where we are and what our
capabilities are
so we have a global presence we have
modality teams in
all around the world that are an initial
point of contact they are in direct
contact with ourselves um our main r d
facility is in cardiff in the uk
and our manufacturing line is also here
so for our dedicated r d line we have
two pilot scale freeze dryers one small
scale r d freeze dryer
we have two
enclosures for packing the lyophilized
product in one is the dry air enclosure
the other is in nitrogen
and we also have several different qc
equipment so we have a
glass transition temperature machine so
that
gives us an indication of how stable
your product is we also have a kf to
determine the moisture content of your
product
we also have both a freeze-drying
microscope and a standard microscope
enabled to
visualize what is going on with the
product
along with this we also have a small lab
in shanghai where we have a r d freeze
dryer we have packing equipment and we
also have a tg and kftc equipment
as mentioned our manufacturing center is
also in cardiff again we have a separate
dedicated manufacturing team and a
separate dedicated manufacturing
laboratory
we can manufacture various different
batch sizes from about 5 000 cakes up to
300 000 beads in per run
to do this we have four different freeze
dryers one batch would go in each freeze
dryer
we have various different
automated liquid dispensing both
automated and semi-automated
manufacturing again have their own
nitrogen enclosures and dry air
enclosures
they're packing the lyophilized products
so you can imagine we've just spent a
while removing all the water from it the
last thing we want to do is expose it to
humid conditions and it picks our water
back up so we package them in
protective environments
once it's then packaged we will then
pouch it to you and put labels on and
the labels we can use
and have all the customer logos on
and then they can be then boxed in the
in whatever boxes is needed
for each manufacturing batch we can also
run quality control so we can confirm
the tg and kf of it
and all of this is run in our cardiff
facility which is for 85
so
going through the process of how
we go from initial contact all the way
through to a manufacture process
so initially
the modality team your local modality
team
and
our team will have a call we'll talk
through
your project your problems what we can
do
and what we think
the final solution will be
we'll then agree on some small scale r d
runs called proof of principle runs in
order to test this out
and
depending on the results the first run
we then
repeat and plan some more
once
both yourselves and us are happy with
the product and the process that we have
developed we will then lock it down and
we will then look to transfer it into
manufacture
now the first thing we would do at this
point is agree with
yourselves what steps we want to take
what bits of the process we want to
validate and then i would present it to
our internal stakeholders so we've got
custom service leader we have
manufacturing leads we've got qa lead
and we've got our technical support lead
i will present to them what we've done
so far what we want to do to transfer
this into manufacture and confirm the
last bits
and we'll get their buy-in all of this
will be captured in design transfer plan
that would be agreed both internally and
also with yourselves
and then the plan will be executed
once the plan has been executed and
we've confirmed the results you've
tested the activity and you're happy
with it we would then
write a report and fully set this
product up in our system
from that point on ubf's order of this
as if it was a standard category product
so during this development you'll be
working directly with us with the
support of our modality team
we
so we would design and transfer and
manufacture this product to your
specifications your packaging your
design
we also have raw materials
that we can store on site and
we recommend that these are drop shipped
to us so customers suppliers like idt
you can order directly from idt and they
will ship to cardiff
so at this point i'd like to hand over
to mitch and you can tell me more about
idt's capabilities
all right well thank you amy um
yeah my name is mitch gore i'm the the
innovation product manager uh one of
them for our core products which is qpcr
and customer legos
so just as by way of overview i just
wanted to let you know that id10 idt
became commercial oligonucleotide
synthesis in the late 1980s and has been
has grown to become a worldwide leader
with over 95 000 individual sequences
produced on an average day
now key to this growth was the
development of the proprietary
and customized synthesis and processing
equipment that we have as well as
workflows and the development of some
innovative technologies for genomics
applications
our customers are widely distributed
across academia in molecular research
synthetic biology and pharmaceutical
research and development
now the heart of idt of course is the
oligonucleotide synthesis and the
fidelity of this process has really been
the key to idt's success
being able to optimize the coupling
efficiency of the synthesis process
allows for us to maximize the full
length yield as well as have improved
outcomes after downstream processing
so our main facility in coralville
is where we're where most of our work
happens but we also have manufacturing
sites in san diego california research
triangle park in north carolina move in
belgium and in singapore and we also
have a satellite r d facility in redwood
california
as we discussed earlier a key to the
success of idt is the ability to control
coupling efficiency
via the development of proprietary
synthesis equipment and processes
now another key is the optimization of
the other aspects of the business such
as raw materials sourcing and qc custom
software to support our limb systems
establishment of customer care groups
specialized to the needs of the
customers and our dedication to product
qc via the development of unique systems
that accurately report on the quality of
the products
so while we have the capacity to make
many different kinds of oligos for the
purposes of today's discussion we wanted
to point out that we routinely
manufacture our legos for several
different conjugation strategies
including those you see here such as
amine chemistries thiols alkenes and
azides for quick chemistry approaches as
well as cholesterol deoxygen and biotin
now as you may know idt makes more than
just primers uh in the context of
today's discussion we will cover idt's
capabilities for primer and pro
production of for qpcr
and those types of assays uh but idt
also has other capabilities with regards
to ngs and crispr so if you have
interest in those please contact us and
we'll be happy to discuss those with you
the idt product evolution is actually
now even including the development of
enzymes and other reagents that are
increasing our footprint and qpcr
gene writing and editing and next
generation sequencing
so now what i'll do is i'll pass it over
to renee and she'll wrap up the
presentation today by telling you a
little bit more about the idt
capabilities
thanks mitch
the four pillars of our strategic
accounts management iso 1345 service are
quality flexibility speed and
personalized support
a typical year is over 90 000 all ago
synthesized under iso 1345 manufacturing
we have two iso 1345 production sites
one in our main facility in coralville
and the other in our louvre belgium
location
these two sites serve over 500
organizations and produce over a
thousand individual assays or oem
products
strategic accounts management services
at idt include dedicated support during
the manufacturing verification and
product validation processes
this is a collaborative process that
strives to establish qc metrics and
reporting formats that ensure lots a lot
consistency and functionality
the customer has access to product
traceability information about the
materials used in the manufacturing
instrumentation
the idt open door policy for on-site
process and product auditing facilitates
the establishment of these metrics and
helps maintain them over time
a very large part of the strategic
accounts management iso 1345 service is
providing oligonucleotides for
qpcr-based detection methodology
these reagents can be convent for
conventional qpcr as well as digital pcr
and include a wide range of fluorophores
and quenchers for singleplex and
multiplex applications and are often
free of ip restrictions
an important aspect of our strategic
account management services is working
with our customers to ensure long-term
growth and satisfaction
to this end we are open to developing
pricing and inventory programs that help
mitigate risks associated with the
finished product launch and scale up
we are also happy to establish a supply
agreement that can lock in pricing over
a defined period of time
define payment terms and ensure
consistency of supply
as well as cover confidentiality and
intellectual property
large-scale synthesis can be done for
research applications as well as
applications that require iso 1345
while confidential confidentiality rules
are adhered to for all of our projects
confidentiality agreements between idt
and the customer can be established at
any point in the relationship
many of the same services such as mixing
aliquoting qc aliquots and kitting that
are applied to regular scale synthesis
projects can be applied to large-scale
projects
to dig a bit deeper into the custom
formulation and kitting options idt
offers you can see here that this can
also include custom aliquoting replicate
plating and a selection of plate types
and tubes our services can also provide
custom labels and packaging as well as
include the packaging of certain
third-party reagents
idt can also provide custom buffers and
order integration and drop shipping
services
and with that that is the end of our
content for today thank you very much
thank you matthew amy mitch and renee
for your informative presentation we
will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question here is for mitch at idt this
question asks how do idt and sativa work
together to manage projects
well both companies you know offer
support throughout the process all the
way from product specification and
development through the final product
um since both companies are part of
danifer we we have you know we have
similar cultures you know we that which
reduces the barriers that you might
experience between the companies that
aren't in the same organization
uh so you know that helps with better
transitions and also helps with
communication between companies
great thank you
our next question here is for matthew at
saitiva this question asks you mentioned
sativa and idt reagents being used as
part of the lyophilization excuse me um
lyophilization mix
please can you explain more about the
compulsion composition excuse me
yeah sure so sativa has a range of
different exception blends and these are
really critical for the authorization
process um at the moment you know we're
developing different blends all the time
we currently have seven different blends
and and these are really tailored to the
specific format that we've got for layer
um but also in terms of particularly um
you know molecular diagnostics pcr
molecular diagnostics are pretty much
our you know most common assay that we
lay off lies and and some of these
different blends are really tailored to
you know a lampasai a qpcr essay or
indeed an rttcr
um and the
the the exceptions themselves really
help maintain the tertiary structure
and the
[Music]
sensitivity of the raw materials
particularly when they're going through
the different temperatures and pressures
um of the localization process
um and indeed key to you know
particularly
with the the pcr assays that we they
offer lies most of the time the oligo is
obviously a very key component of those
along with the primers and probes and an
idt or one of the world leaders in
manufacturing and those key raw
materials so i think between sativa and
idt um you know it's a really good
partnership and differentiate in the
market for our customers who want that
low authorization process
great thank you
this next question here is for renee
renee can idt specifically formulate for
a final lyophilized product
we offer many options of formulations in
kitting to supply a product that can be
customer specified or specified by
sativa
we can work directly with saita to
produce a product that meets the
customer's final specifications
we can drop ship oligos to sativa
and we can collaborate we can
collaborate um directly with sativa on
your behalf
thank you
all right next question here is again
for mitch this question asks are the
lagos different between small scale and
large-scale synthesis
well analytically they're the same
however we work with customers all the
time to do validation as required by
their quality management systems or any
other any other system they might be
working with when we do go through scale
up process changes so it's a fairly
routine process for us
great thank you next question here is
for matthew again
why would someone choose a lyophilized
cake rather than a bead format
um there's a few several differences in
terms of the two formats um i think a
lot of the times the excipient blends
that we use are exactly the same so from
a functionality point of view there's
very little if any difference i think
really the two key differentiators are
the you know the forecaster that the
customer wants uh and also the volume uh
of the reaction and that the customer
wants layoffa lights so from the the
cake side of things in terms of the cake
format it's really tailored towards
the small to medium
super customer um that's low flying
typically anything from five to 100
microliters
um
the different batch values for the case
typically and again you know kind of
referring to a 96-well pcr plate um
normally between around five and twenty
thousand reactions in a in a single
batch
um the differentiator with these is that
the bead format is really tailored
towards more high super customers um who
are lyophilizing again the typical tcr
reactions that are between the kind of
five and 30 microliter range
the typical batch size for these can be
anything as low as five but more
importantly anything up to around you
know even 350 000 beads um per
production per batch so
again the excipients are primarily the
same but it's really tailored towards
what the customer's
demand is and how much volume and
they're uplifting
thank you matthew
next question we have here is for amy
amy how does lyophilization extend the
life of an assay
so there's a lot of aspects to extending
shelf life and during lyophilization
when we've added the excipients and
frozen enjoy the
product we then end up with a solid cake
now in a solid the reagents can't move
around so you can't get any non-specific
amplification
or any degradation of your enzymes
because they are fixed in shape
especially with the excipients in there
that will hold the active ingredient or
your enzymes in the
correct orientation that they need to
maintain activity
the other real advantage of localization
is that it not only stabilizes your
assets for long-term storage but it also
does this at room temperature and if
you're talking about things like point
of care devices or even just being able
to ship around the world and store at
room temperature that's a massive
advantage so you can have a complete
assay that's stabilized at room
temperature
thank you amy
our next question here is for matthew
again
this question asks have you noticed
sustainability becoming more important
reason for companies embarking on
lyophilization
so the the life stable services
from safety that for the past 10 years
and
i think one of the key advantages for
for the service has certainly been
you know the reduced size uh the weight
uh and the quantity of shipments and
obviously the cost
uh associated with that reduction um but
over the years and certainly from the
conversations that we've had with
customers and the research that we've
done
is that there's been a subtle change in
terms of the same questions being asked
but rather from a
rather being from a cost point of view
it's generally tailored more now towards
sustainability and that goes you know
throughout the service really uh and
that's something obviously from an
authorization point of view is something
that
you know is a really strong
differentiator um because it reduces you
know the really
energy energy uh heavy
production of dry ice uh and certainly
the the polystyrene boxes as well would
go with you know anything that you're
shipping around the world
on dry ice so yeah it's certainly
changed throughout the years
and tailored now much more towards the
sustainability side of things
great thank you
our next question here is for amy have
you biophilized exosome products
so yes we have done some
we have likewise exosomes and
predominantly on a small scale in r d we
have
run a few successful experiments it's
not something we've yet put into
manufacture but it's definitely
something that we'd be interested in
getting a go and working with somebody
to develop a procedure for that
right and it looks like we have time for
one more question here and this one is a
two-part question and i'm going to pass
it over to amy as well so this question
asks typically how long should be
anticipated in the development process
to lock the lyo recipe
eg weeks months question mark and second
part here after locking the recipe what
are typical times for mfg a small or
large batch
so
a lot of this depends on the type of
assay that we're locking down
so
if we're doing a fairly standard qpcr
assay or something similar to what we've
done before and we're using slight fever
excipients
often fairly quick to
find a liar program that works we would
often do several small scale proof of
principle runs
over the space of well our turnaround
time for a proof of principle run is
expected to be two weeks from having all
the reagents on site here in cardiff
and a lot of the time in between plot
fronts will be dependent on how quickly
our customers can test it and what
issues we come across on route so we
often can lock a recipe down fairly
early in the first run or two but what
we then can do is start tweaking the
formulation slightly maybe we need to
add in more enzyme and maybe we need to
add in more recipients maybe we need to
add in more magnesium things like that
so we work with
um each of our customers to
lock down both the lyo protocol and also
the formulation
once we're happy that that formulation
is locked down
and again that can be anything from a
couple of weeks to
years depending on the state of time we
will work as fast as the customer while
making sure that we don't have
any so we
we run for thirteen four eight five
we're
gonna develop it to those standards but
we will work with the customer to meet
what deadlines we can that they need us
to meet
after we locked it down we would then
look to transfer this into manufacture
so i would present all the work we've
done to math to qa manufacture technical
support
and confirm that they're happy with what
we've done and also put together a plan
of what we need to move this into
manufacture
now this validation step can take
anything from three months upwards
again if there are deadlines there are
things we can look at to help with that
and then once it's in manufacture and
set up the typical lead time in
manufacture would be two to three months
but
master anything you wanted to know
i agree with you i think from from a
lead time um
yeah it would certainly be in that you
know six to ten week uh region um and we
should i mean that the manufacturing
side is here in the uk um but we
certainly should obviously shift
globally as well so that includes the
shipping time and up to the customer
whatever they are in the world so yeah
well thank you again matthew amy mitch
and renee for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsors saitiva
and idt for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
thank you for joining us until next time
take care everyone goodbye
you